so if we were to ask ourselves what is
the value of our function approaching as
we approach X as we approach x equals 2
from values less than x equals 2 so as
you imagine as we approach x equals 2 so
x equals 1 x equals 1.5 x equals 1.9 x
equals 1.999
x equals one point nine nine nine nine
nine nine nine nine what is f of X
approaching and we see that f of X seems
to be approaching seems to be
approaching this value seems to be
approaching this value right over here
it seems to be approaching five and so
the way we would denote that is the
limit the limit of f of X as X
approaches two and we're going to
specify the direction as X approaches 2
from the negative direction we put the
negative as a superscript after the two
to denote the direction that we're
approaching this is not a negative two
we're approaching 2 from the negative
direction we're approaching 2 from
values less than 2 we're getting closer
and closer to two but from below one
point nine one point nine nine one point
nine nine nine nine nine as X gets
closer and closer to from those values
what is f of X approaching and we see
here that it is approaching it is
approaching five it is approaching five
but what if we were asked a different
question or I guess the the natural
other question what is the limit what is
the limit of f of X as X approaches 2
from values greater than two so this is
a little superscript positive right over
here so now we're going to approach x
equals two but we're going to approach
it from this direction x equals three x
equals two point five x equals two point
one x equals two point zero one x equals
two point zero zero zero one we're going
to get closer and closer to but we're
coming from values that are larger than
two so here when x equals three f of X
is here when x equals two point five f
of X f of X is here when x equals two
point oh one f of X looks like it's
right over here so in this situation
we're getting closer and closer we're
getting closer and closer to f of X
equaling one it never does quite equal
that
actually then just has a jump
discontinuity but it seems to be
approaching this seems to be the
limiting value when we approach X from
values greater that when we approach 2
from values greater than 2 so this right
over here is equal to 1 and so this is
and so when we think about limits in
general the only way that a limit at 2
will actually exist is if both of these
limits these both of these one-sided
limits are actually the same thing in
this situation they aren't as we
approach 2 from values below 2 we are
proceeding 5 and is we approach 2 from
values above 2 the function seems to be
approaching 1 so in this case the limit
let me write this down the limit of f of
X as X approaches 2 from the negative
direction does not equal does not equal
the limit of f of X as X approaches 2
from the positive direction and since
this is since this is the case that
they're not equal the limit does not
exist the limit as X approaches 2 in
general of f of X so the limit of f of X
is X the limit of f of X as X approaches
2 does not exist does not exist in order
for to have existed these two things
would have had to been equal to each
other for example if someone were to say
what is the limit what is the limit of f
of X as X approaches 4 as X approaches 4
well then we can think about the the two
one-sided limits the left the the
one-sided limit from below and the
one-sided limit from above so we could
say well let's see the limit of f of X
as X approaches 4 from below so let me
draw that so what we care about x equals
4 as x equals 4 from below so when x
equals 3 we're here where f of f of 3 is
negative 2 f of 3.5 seems to be right
over here
f of 3 point 9 seems to be right over
here F of 3 point 9 9 9 we're getting
closer and closer to our function
equaling equaling negative
five so this the limit as we approach
for from below this one-sided limit from
the left we could say this is going to
be equal to negative five and if we were
to ask ourselves the limit of f of X as
X approaches 4 from the right from
values larger than four X approaches 4
from the right well same exercise f of
five gets us here f of five f of 4.5
seems right around here f of 4.1 seems
right about here f of four point zero
one seems right around here and even F
of four is actually defined but we're
getting closer and closer to it and we
see once again we are approaching five
we are approaching five even if F of
four was not defined on either side we
would be approaching five or I sorry we
would be approaching negative five so
this is also approaching negative five
and since the limit from the left-hand
side is equal to the limit from the
right hand side we can say so these two
things are equal and because these two
things are equal we know that the limit
of f of X as X approaches four is equal
to five let's look at a few more
examples so let's ask ourselves let's
ask ourselves the limit the limit of f
of X now this is our new f of X depicted
here as X approaches 8 and let's
approach 8 from the left as f as X
approaches 8 from values less than 8 so
what's this going to be equal to it I
encourage you to pause the video to try
to figure it out yourself so X is
getting closer and closer to 8 so if X
is 7 f of 7 is here if X is 7.5 F of 7.5
is here so it looks like our value of f
of X is getting closer and closer and
closer to 2 3 so it looks like the limit
of f of X as X approaches 8 from the
negative side is equal to 3 what about
from the positive side what about the
limit of f of X as X approaches 8 from
the positive direction or from the right
side well here we see as X as X is 9
this is our f of X as X is 8 point 5
this is our F of 8 point 5 it seems like
we're pro
King it seems like we're approaching f
of X equaling one so notice these two
limits are different so the limit
actually does the the non one-sided
limit or the two-sided limit does not
exist at f of X or at as we approach
eight so let me write that down the
limit of f of X as X approaches 8
because these two things are not the
same value this does not exist does not
does not exist let's do one more example
in here they're actually asking us a
question the function f is graphed below
what appears to be the value of the
one-sided limit the limit of f of X this
is f of X as X approaches 2 from the
negative direct or sorry it's X approach
is negative 2 from the negative
direction so this is the negative 2 from
the negative direction so we care what
happens as X approaches negative 2 we
see f of X is actually undefined right
over there but let's see what happens as
we approach from the negative direction
or as we approach from values less than
negative 2 or as we approach from the
left as we approach from the left F of
negative 4 is right over here so this is
F of negative 4 F of negative 3 is right
over here negative 3 is right over there
F of negative 2 point 5 seems to be
right over here we seem to be getting
closer and closer to f of X be equal to
4 at least visually so I would say that
it looks at least graphically the limit
of f of X as X approaches 2 from the
negative Direction is equal to 4 now if
we also asked ourselves the limit of f
of X as X approaches negative 2 from the
positive direction we would get a
similar result where now we're going to
approach from when x is 0 f of X seems
to be right over here when X is 1 f of X
is right over here when X is 1 point
negative 1 point 9 9 when it exercises
well this is when X is negative 1 f of X
is there when X is negative 1 point 9 f
of X seems to be good right over here so
once again we seem to be getting closer
and closer to 4 because the left handed
limit and the right handed limit
same value because both one-sided limits
are approaching the same thing we can
say that the limit of f of X as X
approaches 2 I'm sorry as X approaches
negative 2 and this is from both
direction since from both directions we
get the same limiting value we can say
that the limit exists there and it is
equal to 4